hey guys welcome into bar naka of
Capitol Hill in Seattle wit got Rudy
Pepe Eli today we'll be making the
Gospels guarded amid classic little sour
play with some charcoal and some other
fun ingredients we're gonna start with
our Bombay Sapphire how far up - we're
gonna go to the 1 and 3/4 market then
how that swag out pinkies out what's
going in the little bag it's going in
the little guy
now moving our Bombay we're gonna move
on to our acid so to be a little - lemon
juice let's go 3/4 of this guy as well
cut with 3/4 on this thing where would I
be
right under the 1 ounce line got it and
then let's move on to our ginger syrup
okay so if you look at the kind of
components we have our base spirit we
have our acid we have a sugar Sweeting
agent can you just buy this it's breezy
too many mate hot syrup a little bit of
ginger in it master it to your own kind
of heat like a 10 gram - 1 ounce of
serve as pretty salt so again so how
much lemon do we put in there 3/4 of an
ounce the same here always match your
acid with your sugar ok done done done
here we go here we go in an in its now
we have a base of a sour spirit acid
sugar never get to you little creative
aspect start with our egg whites they're
nice
1 ounce it's just gonna be a pure
protein not a flavor additive but a
textural additive right there's nothing
more attractive than one ounce of egg
white right egg whites in front right
get it in there
so charcoal solution gives you a perfect
texture and color can you make this at
home this is I actually get it in the
house section of any large grocery chain
oh so I mean it's a good thing for your
stomach actually with this guy only 1/2
ounce
well shake shake there we go
trust your team trust your team half
ounce one team one three magic and now
back to it bring it home to Seattle
Scrappy's file out a tincture and it's
delicious it's gonna be a little bit of
kick it's gonna remind you about that
gospel that truth so one strong - I said
that's a couple of dashes boom all right
so now with the egg white you're gonna
have one capacity of dilution with your
ice but also you're agitating it so we
only have to use half the amount of ice
shake for the same amount of time so the
ice is gonna agitate give that froth :
you get more exactly it's your - we're
only making one cocktail per shaker so
half is perfect so I have a cobbler
shaker this is an easy seal for me you
gentlemen we're gonna go down angle
perfect I like it and when we shake
large faced out so if it does explode
and try to kill somebody hit me exactly
to get the ice front to back so just
we're getting better at this
good good good get it I'm gonna get it
nope nope we'll see that one angle right
here so notice the seal light to the
left will break oh you've done this
before
a couple times me yeah now gentlemen do
you guys grab your strainers grab your
glass we're free right in front of you
so double-strain you put it exactly
right take your time and I'ma stay like
tap on the side oh my god I'm so proud
of myself
look at that yes nice bra color is right
now I have a little garnish some more
charcoal solution on top but with a
dropper nice and delicate about inch
above the surface pretty little dots
it's great okay this is all Ryan's belt
just navigate trust your heart trust
your soul I'll take a little pics that
we got yep Pierce that has little hearts
mine looks like arrows Pratt beautiful
this is how we make the Gospels dirty
cheers gentlemen
Cheers what are we toasting to you that
toasting to the bar Seattle to Seattle
of course toasting to Seattle there we
go there we go oh my goodness thank you
so much it's great I think so try this
drink for leaves so much beauty in like
it's really intense thank you gentlemen